Và tôi điểm đường bố đang dây vào cạnh của ta dơ cao điểm
Vũ chiếc xe ao to cho tiêu ra ring có sản phố đang chuyển ra con kể đã bố cùng vọng rạc
Nhận thấy tình hình quyết cấp người ta sẽ là hả kính
Bộ bán ra yêu bắt đầu cứu lúc lần cạnh xác sau to ngào làm như bụ gần đó
Để được hó cho đưa đến bánh viện nhiên nhất có thể
Lai là bất không một chút chần chứ
Các chiếc xí cạnh xác sau to ngào bói ngọng cơ ki quyết loa bạc ki thời
Hánh đầu cần chung, nhé trong lạ hiểu là nhiều tiết
Ghiều có phương tiền xúc quan tập xa này đường
Nhưng lại một khoảng chống lòng rai
Họ cho tùng xuất, chứ tiết vào được
Rất nó ăn giúp cho xe chở sản phố bữa sống qua và rường tắc em
Để đến bánh viện ăn qua và nhên chống nhé